Nói ngọt luôn nhẹ, một chào liêu chờ là kính nhiều người thường lạc với năm 2020.
Thế hệ Mila Ngo sài là dễn dễn rồi đâu.
Anh hảm bất còn nữ thời mà người người dụ nhau,
xanh các ngọt của các ula của Intel Xean của mình.
Bình đồng mối nhà được của Intel một loàn của các ula Intel.
Sau mời năm, nhiều người không hỏi bất ngờ khi bắt gặp lại,
những loàn của các ula Intel xuất hiện khắp nơi từ sư thiệt.
Gởi hàng được lợi đến cả tiện tạm tạm á đúng không?
Không chỉ Intel.
Các loàn của các ula của Intel nhỏ,
của lợi mặt mà, của đợp là như hỗ em à,
này hội cái đẹp.
Không chỉ dưới chè, mặt cả thế,
Bilanio cũng nhập cuộc lệ ôn lại gì niệp.
Hàng loại các lợi dùng sáng tạo ra đời từ nối từ,
nghe bọn, hay tập chỉ là chế miếm.
Không có gì có thể làm họ được dưới chè.
Không tin được tin, tin mình từ tạo,
các bạn chè dù nhau ra các bút của các ula để Intel mà theo ý thích.
nhiều trong tin nên tục lên bài,
trong thế này đã mặt bình lớn tương tắc đều qua mà điện thoại.
Chào liêu của các ula lại mang đến những cách nối thực.
Hoàn toàn khắc bỏ.
Đây cũng là lý dò rút,
in xe ra lòng Intel của cuộc cả của la,
tấn dưới đại xương hút sau hơn một tập kì.
Sương dân bài thôi,
giờ em cũng ra xương tìm xanh lòng đây.